[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le mardi 7
novembre
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition une période délicate traversée
par le parti socialiste des yvelines en
octobre la fédération a perdu sa
première secrétaire depuis 2012 sandrine
grand grande qui a décidé de se mettre
en retrait exclu de son parti pour avoir
rejoint nouveau groupe au conseil
régional d'île de france comment
voit-elle son avenir et celui des
socialistes alors qu'un congrès national
se tient en février sandrine dans le
grand bain notre invité elle a effectué
toute sa carrière au sein du ps le
portrait de la rédaction est consacrée à
catherine tasca l'ancien ministre
députée et sénatrice a pris sa retraite
politique dans ce journal
retour sur 20 années de parcours de
l'exécutif au législatif
et puis c'est un événement exceptionnel
ce samedi la boxe investi le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour le main event 4 et tout ce combat
de prestige au programme est sur le ring
à l'élan pour toi a dit la môme a dit il
défendra sa ceinture de champion
d'europe des poids super moyens une
initiative inédite hier une quarantaine
de députés de toutes tendances
politiques ont se sont rendus à
simultanément dans plusieurs prisons
françaises appels lancés par la
présidente de la commission des lois la
députée et les oem de la 5e
circonscription des yvelines heilbronn
peavey elle a visité la maison d'arrêt
de bois d'arcy où sont incarcérés 976
détenus pour une capacité théorique de
100 5 162 places et des déplacements
pour alimenter les discussions sur les
conditions carcérales au programme de la
commission des lois ce matin et dans
l'actualité également seize jeunes aux
yvelinois rentrer qui rentrent
officiellement dans l'armée de terre ils
ont assigné ce matin leur contrat
d'engagement à la mairie de versailles
en présence du général de corps d'armée
francis autran une carrière militaire
s'offre désormais à eux avec à la clé
une formation et un métier propos
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est une grande émotion c'est une
grande fierté c'est quelque chose que
j'attendais depuis un moment donc
beaucoup d'émotion est vraiment beaucoup
de fierté en fait un gros engagement
pour engagement dans l'armée
un aboutissement parce que j'ai quand
même dû travailler pour
pour l'épauler concours tout ça donc
beaucoup de travail et enfin un
aboutissement
ça permet à des jeunes gens d'avoir
d'abord une mise en formation
ça leur permet d'envisager ici le
souhaite bien entendu un parcours
professionnel complet
ça leur permet éventuellement de pouvoir
obtenir des expériences et des
expertises dans des domaines
particuliers et 15 à 20 jeunes sont
recrutés par mois dans les yvelines par
lan l'armée de terre qui a de réels
besoins 15000 postes sont à pourvoir
cette année et en 2018
on accueille sur ce plateau sandrine un
grand grand bonsoir ça conseil régional
élu attrapé saint quentin en yvelines
vous étiez également récemment encore
première secrétaire fédérale du parti
socialiste des yvelines
ça c'était jusqu'au mois dernier vous
avez décidé de vous mettre en retrait de
la fédération après votre exclusion du
parti socialiste une décision du parti
de vos instances nationales
suite à votre décision de créer un
nouveau groupe au conseil régional
d'ile-de-france un groupe que vous avez
créé avec d'autres ex élu socialiste et
à des élus écologistes notamment benoît
hamon dont vous êtes proche et d'autres
élus au monde de cette décision vous
envisagiez de déposer un recours contre
cette exclusion de votre parti est ce
que vous y avait renoncé à ce recours
si vous voulez on c'est un parti qui va
mal parti socialiste s'est pas c'est pas
un scoop et on a des dizaines de
militants qui partent chaque jour et
dans la période la direction nationale
ne trouve rien de mieux que d'exclure
des des gens regardent une circulaire
j'ai pas entrer dans les détails c'est
pas très intéressant à mon avis mais qui
sur le plan juridique est quand même
très très faible d'ailleurs rifi les
pythies a décidé de déposer un recours
donc effectivement la question je me la
supposait de est-ce que je pose un
recours ce qui me permet de rester aux
participants sachant que ce recours est
suspensif
je revienne sur les cheveux j'aurais pu
rester au parti socialiste le temple
recours soient étudiées et j'ai
certainement jusqu'au prochain congrès
et en même temps rester à la tête de la
fédération
moi j'ai décidé de me retirer de la
fédération d'edel annonce de cette
démission d'office qui m'a été notifié
et parce que je ne voulais pas que la
fédération soit dans mêlé à cette
histoire pour sa conscience ou le
conseil régional où nous on a estimé
qu'on ne pouvait plus travailler
sereinement dans le groupe tel qu'il
était constituée du parti socialiste
pour ça vous avez créé un nouveau groupe
c pour ça reconnaissait plus dans
n'arrivait pas se reconnaissait plus
dans la manière dont le groupe était
gérée par un proche de manuel valls
donc c'est ce qui avait conduit à faire
à constituer ce groupe trans partisan
donc je me suis posé effectivement la
question de savoir ce que j'allais faire
et les deux questions en réalité je me
suis posée c'est est ce que je crois en
l'avenir politique de ce parti et est ce
que je crois que je peux moi en tant que
militants de continuer d'y militer de
défendre mais mais mais hésite et
maintenant et à ces deux questions là je
force est de constater que la réponse
est non tiens je ne pense pas
aujourd'hui que l'avenir de la gauche
la reconstruction de la gauche va se
faire autour du parti socialiste
malheureusement j'espère cela avec le
parti c'est votre avenir beaucoup de
naître du côté de benoît hamon on sait
que vous êtes proche de benoît hamon qui
a créé son mouvement du 1er juillet ça
peut être il ya un mouvement qui a
vocation à devenir un parti politique
donc toute façon cette question là ce
serait posée elle s'est posé un peu plus
tôt pour moi mais elle se pose je sais
pour de nombreux socialistes de savoir
où est-ce qu'on est le plus à même
d'être utile pour les idées comporte et
aujourd'hui moi je fais le constat que
c'est dans ce que développe benoît hamon
comme comme idée et autour de la
structure qui va constituer que je vais
pouvoir porter les idées auxquelles je
suis attaché et plus au sein de ma
famille même si je continuais y avoir de
nombreux de nombreux amis et de nombreux
personnes qui défendent des idées
communes mais vraiment je pense
qu'aujourd'hui l'avenir de la gauche va
se faire autour d'autres structures le
parti socialiste on l'a vu dans les
derniers résultats électoraux et
aujourd'hui vraiment renvoyer une image
très passéiste qui correspondent pas du
tout à ce que les gens attendent vous
avez l'impression de quitter un navire
qui est en train de couler parce que ce
que c'est le cas j'espère que non
j'espère que le ce parti va réussir à
retrouver le bon cap
je ne suis pas persuadé donc ça que je
pense que abandonné la gauche va se
reconstruire avec des structures
politiques et j'espère que le parti
socialiste en sera mais je les décisions
qui sont prises par la direction
nationale
indépendamment des histoires d'exclusion
on voit que c'est des règlements de
comptes politiques
on sait des choses assez classique mais
mais il ya d'autres phénomènes plus
graves où elle ce parti est inaudible
instants n'a pas une voix qui porte et
et qui permettent de porter des idées de
gauche
petite pause dans cet entretien avec le
portrait de la rédaction comme chaque
mardi dans le 7-8 journal il est
consacré une personne que vous
connaissez très bien sans d'un gang
c'est catherine tasca
elle a mis fin à sa carrière politique
en décidant de ne pas se présenter pour
un nouveau mandat de sénatrice retour
sur son parcours du parlement au
gouvernement avec nicolas d'andry
discussion du projet de loi confiance
dans l'action publique au sénat le 11
juillet 2010 cette dernière prise de
parole de catherine tasca en tant que
sénatrice des yvelines
à propos des emplois familiaux des
parlementaires mais il suffirait pour ce
faire d'encadrer strictement ces
embauches familial comme d'ailleurs a su
le faire désormais le sénat en limitant
à un seul emploi ce type de recrutement
et en plafonnant le niveau de
rémunération ses premiers pas dans les
yvelines catherine tasca les faits en
1997 la direction du parti socialiste
l'a choisie comme candidate pour les
élections législatives anticipées dans
la 12e circonscription la campagne
électorale une nouveauté pour la
socialiste
il faut évidemment tenir compte du monde
militant d'abord des adhérents de son
propre parti ensuite de la famille
politique de l'ensemble de la gauche
mais il faut surtout découvrir les
habitants et tenir compte deux parce que
ça c'est l'autre monde et c'est le monde
pour lequel en réalité on est là pour sa
première élection elle est élue députée
face au candidat rpr udf jean michel
fourgous très très heureuse
vous dites une victoire serrée moi je
trouve que par rapport aux précédentes
élections c'est une grande victoire
je suis très heureuse et comme vous le
dites je suis peut-être doublement
heureuse parce que c'est la première
fois que je vis cette émotion
c'est formidable parce que c'est une
victoire partagée et avec beaucoup de
monde
députée elle présidera la commission des
lois elle participe aussi à
l'inauguration du bâtiment vauban de
l'université versailles saint quentin
une cérémonie aux côtés du premier
ministre lionel jospin il nommera
catherine tasca au ministère de la
culture en 2000 un retour aux sources
elle qui a occupé des postes
ministériels à la rue de valois entre
1988 et 1993
cette maison ne m'est pas inconnue j'y
reviens avec l'infini plaisir en même
temps croyez moi avec la conscience
aiguë que en quelques années beaucoup de
choses ont bougé je ne siègerait plus
dans l'hémicycle mais je continuerai à
me sentir député des yvelines est en
tout cas à maintenir un contact très
étroit avec la circonscription lors de
l'élection présidentielle de 2002
catherine tasca soutien à son tour
lionel jospin aux côtés de jean paul
huchon ou encore de françois hollande
lors d'un meeting organisé à bois d'arcy
le 21 avril 2002 est vécu comme un échec
cuisant
[Musique]
aujourd'hui en 2004 catherine tasca et
élue sénatrice un siège de parlementaire
qu'elle quitte aujourd'hui après 13
années de mandature
c'est un changement qui
de fait et douloureux parce que moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé le sénat est donc là j'ai
travaillé pour les yvelines pour les
yvelines et aussi pour l'ensemble du
pays mais c'est là que cfm on attache
très forte avec les yvelines entre
territoires des yvelines et une passion
pour la culture catherine tasca met un
terme à cette partition politique sur
une note de mozart un compositeur
qu'elle apprécie est la conseillère
régionale sont des grandes orgues qui
est toujours avec nous sur ce plateau
petite réaction à ce sujet abondent
c'est vous avez pu avoir aussi des
divergences d'idées avec catherine tasca
mais quel regard vous portez sur sa
carrière politique
c'est une grande dame de la politique et
et c'est un beau parcours et ça a permis
d'ouvrir aussi la voie à d'autres femmes
ce qu'elle a montré qu'elle était une
femme compétente travailleuses et normé
mambo c1 c'est incontestable et moi le
seul bémol c'est parce que les
divergences
elles sont minimes au regard de ce qui
peut ne nous rapprocher mais je regarde
qu'elle était un soutien indéfectible au
gouvernement de manuel valls et qui a eu
à mener même jusqu'en juin à vouloir la
victoire de parlementaire proche de
manuel mâcon même si en septembre elle a
un petit peu changé sa manière de voir
les choses mais c'est vrai que ça nous a
fait beaucoup de mal dans les yvelines
après il ya tout ce qu'elle a apporté ça
fait pas c'est bien sûr cette ces
derniers mois
ça les met de côté on va dire et elle a
les soutenions le rappelle manuel valls
lors de la dernière primaire de gauche
dernière partie de cet entretien c'est
une grande grande un échelon plus local
vous êtes conseillère communautaire
d'opposition de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération qui a depuis le mois
dernier un nouveau président le maire
les républicains d'elancourt jean michel
fourgous la majorité droite qui a
proposé à l'opposition de gauche 4
postes de vice présidence est ce que il
y à un accord est ce que vous avez vous
allez accepter ces postes de vice
présidence
nous ça fait les quatre villes de gauche
depuis le début de cette mandature on
demande à participer à l'exécutif on
demande à être partie prenante en fait
de l'avenir de ce territoire puisque on
pèse aussi dans ce territoire et puis
qu'il ya des clivages qui sont parfois
indépendant de des parcours politique
qui sont liés au territoire réellement
donc ça paraissait normal on a entendu
la demande de jean-michel fourgous qui
est de d'accepter cette cette
proposition de participer après il ya
une charte de gouvernance qu'on veut
vraiment mettre en place avec nos
collègues pour que ça marche
dès que le négociateur de haut qui a
encore des négociations à la fois sur
les périmètres et puis sur sur comment
on fait comme on travaille à 12
et là il faut avancer avec lui tous les
maires mais sur le principe je crois
qu'il ya un accord qui se dessine
merci sens rennes-caen grande d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle conseillère
régionale élue à saint quentin en
yvelines est également à la ville de
trappes trappe ou des entreprises ont
coaché dix stagiaires c'était ce matin
l'école de la deuxième chance des
yvelines organiser des entretiens
d'embauché test pour ces élèves
plusieurs sociétés locales ont joué le
jeu pour aider ces jeunes sans diplôme à
s'entraîner tout au long d'un pardon
pardon danser dans les conditions
presque réel des conditions presque réel
c'est un reportage de nicolas
kirillovitch un candidat deux recruteurs
toutes les conditions sont réunies pour
donner l'impression à mehdi qu'ils
passent un entretien d'embauché
il s'agit pourtant d'un entraînement
pour le jeune homme comme lui les
stagiaires de l'école de la deuxième
chance des yvelines font face ce matin
là à des professionnels pendant 25
minutes
objectif les tester mais surtout leur
donner confiance avant de décrocher un
vrai rendez vous
voilà c'est courage bientôt ça leur
permet de se situer en fin de compte
dans leur accompagnement ça leur permet
de prendre confiance en eux dans le
cadre de leur démarche de travail et
leur projet professionnel avec plus de
confiance de de pouvoir s'épanouir
qu'ils étaient positifs ils m'ont dit
que vu que c'était une passion que je
voulais mettre en oeuvre dans un métier
ça pourrait être intéressant j'aurai
tout pour conquérir
en tout 25 jeunes ont participé à cette
matinée spéciale pour les aider dit
recruteurs locaux ont répondu à l'appel
ce premier contact avec le monde de
l'entreprise doit permettre aussi à ses
stagiaires en formation depuis plusieurs
mois de diversifier leurs compétences il
ya le marché de l'emploi et on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de concurrence dans le
marché de l'emploi il faut que ces
jeunes soient prêts aussi à faire face à
ceux à ce marché de l'emploi et cette
concurrence et pour ça il faut qu'ils
puissent réussir à faire un super
entretien pouvoir décrocher leurs
premiers de leur premier emploi
depuis leur lancement il ya vingt ans
les écoles de la deuxième chance sont
accueillis des jeunes sans diplôme de 16
à 25 ans en 2016 85 % des stagiaires ont
bénéficié d'une sortie positive
alternance formation qualifiante ou
contrat aidé le département des yvelines
compte trois écoles dont une à saint
quentin en yvelines
le très haut dans le très haut débit
dans les yvelines pardon excusez moi qui
vient de franchir une nouvelle étape ce
matin a été inauguré à base mans une
première armoire de montée en débit
vraie évolution pour les habitants qui
pourraient être équipés à terme de la
fibre optique première armoire d'une
longue série dont le département le
point avec marie pannetrat et camille
lambert
c'est une petite révolution pour cette
commune et ses 1600 habitants située au
coeur de la plaine de versailles un
village rural au charme d'antan mais un
peu coupé des communications numériques
mardi 7 novembre une armoire de montée
en débit a été inaugurée sur la place de
l'église
un événement attendu par les locaux je
pense surtout aux entrepreneurs
indépendants qui sont nombreux dans le
village dont qui travaillent sur place
et qui ont besoin d'une d'une
informatique de de qualité de pouvoir
travailler vite de communiquer vis tu
t'es moyen-âge était justement vous
aviez une journaliste qui disait un
instant qu'elle avait 0 3 dans sa propre
maison qui est au qui justement la
nausée car debasement ceux qui sont la
loire ils ont admis hélas alors la
montée en débit permet d'atteindre en
moyenne de l'ordre de 15 méga 500 foyers
seront alimentés par cette armoire dès
février 2018
objectif à terme accueillir la fibre en
2020 un défi lancé depuis 2016 par le
conseil départemental avec la création
de l'établissement public yvelines
numériques 7 millions d'euros déployés
pour quoi d'abord pour lutter contre la
fracture numérique
il ya aucune raison que les la majorité
des 262 ville de notre département soit
équipée et certaines d'ores et déjà de
très haut débit et que d'autres soit
entre qu'ils veulent et c'est pourquoi
comme base mon 44 autres communes vont
être équipés d'armoires de montée en
débit dans les prochains mois près d'eux
quinze mille foyers sont concernés
une première au vélodrome nationale la
boxe débarque dans l'enceinte
saint-quentinoise pour une soirée
exceptionnelle de main event 4 ce samedi
ouverture des portes à 17 heures douze
matches professionnels
au programme qui mettront aux prises
plusieurs athlètes de la team farruggia
du boxing club de saint quentin en
yvelines
donc notre invité à 10 la môme a dit
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes champion
d'europe des poids super moyens et vous
allez à défendre du coup samedi votre
ceinture face à christopher rebrassé
c'est la fiche de cet événement on peut
le dire ça fait deux ans à dilhac vous
boxez à l'étranger entraînements
notamment en italie
boxer à domicile à saint quentin en
yvelines est ce que ça il ya une
pression particulière pour vous de
revenir positionnement de pression
contraire ça c'est un plaisir de pouvoir
le faire dans les yvelines
voilà on est licencié dans les yvelines
on a évolué dans les yvelines ont appris
la boxe professionnelle dans les
yvelines
eh ben
se mettre en avant dans les yvelines
face sur une ceinture européenne ce et
c'est une fierté et boxer oued dans ce
vélodrome nationale qui est bon une
enceinte d'exception c'était aussi
important pour que la boxe investissent
oui c'est tant mieux la boxe
revient la preuve dans vélodrome ça sera
car à de bons spectacles du mois ya un
bon spectacle il y aura plusieurs
combats et qui mériteront d'être vu en
tout cas
las il y aura pas mal de combat
franco-français il y aura ceinture
européenne ceinture nationale
super que du beau spectacle à voir alors
l'opposition pour vous ça sera face à
quelqu'un que vous connaissez très bien
que liszt offer obras et qui a été à
nombreuses reprises votre sparring
partner voilà j'ai été à plusieurs
reprises son challenger en vain les
combats ne sont jamais faits après on a
eu aussi à plusieurs reprises aussi on a
pu faire disparaître on s'est rendu
service mutuellement
aujourd'hui à il ya un enjeu et puis bah
tant mieux on va pouvoir
boxer ensemble pour un titre important
j'ai entendu dans une autre émission ça
fait à peu près depuis 2012 que vous
vouliez l'affronter bien que je voulais
l'affronter c'est tout simplement j'ai
pu je suis
j'étais son challenger parce que
christopher rebrassé aussi à un champion
il a été plusieurs fois champion
national il a été champion union
européenne champions d u le titre qu'on
va qu'on va jouer ce samedi
et donc c'est ici et c'est un bon boxeur
après on a pu faire disparaître ensemble
quand il en avait besoin pour préparer
ces échéances au même titre que moi
quand j'avais besoin
donc je pense que on savait très bien
pourtant vous appel à l'un comme l'autre
question naïve peut-être quand on
connaît bien sûr l'adversaire et qu'on
s'est beaucoup entraîné avec lui est ce
que ça change la façon d'aborder le
combat pas spécialement après on
travaille sur les erreurs et les
qualités de
dix boxeurs en tout cas de ce qu'on en
sait après je pense que le combat dans
tous les cas tous les combats ne sont
pas les mêmes et le combat n'est pas
sparring voit la rencontre votre son
fils on le connaît très bien a dit
labeaume a dit haut et ça frappe fort
la tête la tactique là samedi à va pas
forcément changé contre lui on la
stratégie n'est pas celle ci le but
c'est comme un boxeur qui tient ses
douze brunoy bus pour moi sera de fermer
deux rooney stratégiquement avec la
tactique qu'il faudra quoi forcer la
deuxième fois que vous remettez en jeu
cette ceinture européenne des poids
super moyens après une volée biais perdu
la dernière fois en contre calvin smith
ça c'est en 2016 a liverpool vous l'avez
reconquis cette ceinture un an plus tard
il n'y a pas d'appréhension particulière
pour samedi
papa de peur de reperdre une nouvelle
fois cette ceinture non pas du tout g
parce que je me laisse pas cette
opportunité là la perdre
si je partais dans cet objectif je le
ferai pas l'idée c'est de viser plus
haut aller chercher quelque chose au
niveau mondial
objectivement je vise plus haut et quand
on perd une première fois cette ceinture
il ya c'est il ya un peu plus d'un an à
tous et y est âgé de 35 ans à l'époque
on vous disait peut-être fini comme on
arrive à seront motivés à se remettre
dans le bain tout de suite et à
reconquérir un an plus tard une ceinture
européenne
je pense que
c'est ce qui fait peut-être partie de
mad men ma force le mental je sais ce
que je veux et puis on n'a rien sans
rien bon je me bat encore pour obtenir
tant que j'ai un objectif il y aura un
objectif en tête pardon je me bats pour
la voir et l'objectif sera de garder
cette ceinture et je vais me battre pour
la garder on reparle juste de l'objectif
vous l'aviez dit avant donc garder cette
ceinture aller chercher peut-être le
terrain mondial après actuellement là
vous êtes âgé de 37 ans est tout à fait
possible c'est possible on a on a on a
encore deux boxeurs qui sont champions
du monde
à 37 ans on est en pleine maturité 2
de discipline je pense qu'avec eux on
part donc en prêt par oui je voulais
dire qu'on prépare le match de samedi la
dernière semaine de préparation ça se
passe comment concrètement une dernière
semaine de préparation avant un match
dernières semaines plus de la répétition
peu de répétitions de la récup
et puis on va pas on va pas ça va savent
plus de plusieurs reports voilà pas de
pression particulière la de la pression
pas du tout parce que le travail a bien
été fait en amont donc l'entraînement a
été suivi comme il le fallait on a pu
avoir de super superbe sparring partner
on a pu avoir d'aidé
du coaching de qualité donc il n'ya
aucune inquiétude derrière dernière
chose petit clin d'oeil à la veille de
ce combat il ya forcément une étape
importante c'est la pesée qui se
déroulera en mairie d'elancourt la
mairie donc vous êtes agent exactement
ils ont donc je suis je suis agent de la
mairie d'elancourt et on fait la pesée à
la mairie d'elancourt qui vous avez
récompensé si je ne m'abuse il ya un an
et demi deux ans à peu près ils m'ont
dit récompenser la ville m'a déjà
récompensé me permet aussi de me
préparer au meilleur niveau pour
pour ces échéances donc
un grand merci aussi et on vous souhaite
bonne chance merci bien ce match samedi
merci a dit labeaume a dit d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle vous serez sur
leur ia samedi soir contre christopher
est brassée à pour dominer 24 vous allez
défendre vous l'avait amené avec vous à
cette ceinture européenne des as poids
super moyens donc ce mail even for c'est
bien sûr au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
ouverture des portes à partir de 17h et
les combats seront à suivre en direct
sur la chaîne canal + sport et ce sera
dès 20h45 merci beaucoup
il était notre invité la semaine
dernière passionné de cinéma depuis tout
petit tony chasselas s'est lancé dans la
réalisation de son second court métrage
un scénario basé sur la relation entre
un mari et sa femme sur fond de meurtre
un tournage suivi ce week end à la
verrière par nicolas landry et les
arrêts ch
bienvenue dans les coulisses du tournage
d'un film à petite échelle caméraman
ingénieur son script et réalisateur
l'équipe de techniciens sur le second
court métrage de tony chasse lass est
quasiment au complet
toi tu suis toujours quand la scène
c'est l'âge est effectivement le bruit
de la sienne qui tombe normalement c'est
un briquet sont fait entendre ça aurait
dû être
[Musique]
méticuleux le réalisateur fait le point
avec son équipe avant de tourner une
scène dans la mise en production d'un
film chaque poste a un rôle bien précis
et son importance cela permet de ne rien
laisser au hasard
je fais stand real c'est à dire que je
suis un peu le chef d'orchestre
j'organise c'est moi qui organisais le
tournage à la préparation j'ai fait le
planning par exemple pour cette seconde
réalisation tony chasse classe a
souhaité réunir une partie de l'équipe
de son premier film là je joue deux
méchants dans le projet d'avant et dans
celui là qui sont opposés deux mois en
fait et donc j'aime j'aime il faut être
quelqu'un d'autre en fait le financement
d'un court métrage est souvent une tâche
délicate si pour son premier film tony
chasse là ce avait fait appel au
cruising il a entièrement autofinancé le
second avec un budget estimé à 1500
euros
cela explique l'équipe réduite autour du
projet le film en fait comme le casting
il est pas très très grand et qu'on
travaille à l'intérieur on a besoin on a
besoin d'un peu moins de monde donc du
coup ça permet d'avoir des personnes
dédiée plutôt concentrées dans titeuf le
film intitulé certes ruem meurtre en
verlan devrait être disponible sur
internet début des 1018 c'est la fin de
ce set 8 journal replay un reportage à
consulter comme d'habitude sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile tablette tv 78 excellente soirée
à tous
[Musique]